Hello everyone and uh welcome to lecture
7 of CME 295.
So today we're going to uh focus on
practical techniques to let our LLM
interact with the outside world with
other systems because um up until now
our LLM was purely on its own. We've
trained it. We've seen how it can reason
on problem math, coding math, coding
problems. And uh now what we want to do
is to use our LLM in the context of
other systems. So today's class we'll
focus on rag that you may have heard
tool calling
and agents.
But before we start as usual I'm going
to recap what we did uh last time. So if
you remember last time we focused on
reasoning models and we saw the
differences between reasoning model and
what we call the vanilla LLM and in
particular up until the lecture before
last lecture. What we saw was we fed a
prompt to the LLM and it gave us
directly a response. But what we saw
last time was that if we let the LLM
reason before outputting the response,
then we can gain some performance when
it comes to reasoning tasks such as math
and coding. And so in particular
reasoning models what they do is they
take a prompt as input and then what
they output is both a reasoning chain
which is typically hidden from the user
and then a response.
So with that we saw how we could train a
model to be more of a reasoning model.
And in particular we saw a core RL
algorithm called GRPO which stands for
group relative policy optimization.
And we saw that this algorithm had some
differences compared to the ones that we
saw previously. And in particular one
notable aspect is that it does not have
it does not train a value function.
So here this uh illustration shows a
little bit how gRPO is trained. So it
takes a query as input and then it
computes an advantage for each output by
um computing the rewards for different
completions of a same prompt and then
computing a quantity which is the
advantage that is relative to the other
rewards of that group of completions.
And then we saw that if we applied GRPO
with carefully chosen rewards which is
one rewarding the model for outputting a
reasoning chain and then second
rewarding the model to for producing a
good response. What we saw is that as
the RL training progresses, we have an
improvement of the model on these
reasoning tasks. And so we saw one of
the tasks being uh math problems. So
here on the left graph you see the
evolution of the performance of the
model on the AIM data set which is a
kind of a challenging math uh problem.
And
we saw that but we also saw that the
model kept on input outputting
responses that were longer and longer.
And in particular we saw that even
though you know towards the end of the
graph above uh that the performance was
kind of plateauing we saw that the
output length was still increasing.
So then what we did was go back to the
loss formulation that is used by gRPO
and realize that there is a term that
makes the contribution of a token
different if it is in a short response
or a long response.
So this is a phenomenon called length
bias and we saw some mitigation
strategies that were explored by some
papers that came out uh in the past few
months. So one was DAPo which um had a a
normalization factor that was not
dependent on where the token was located
on which sentence it was located. And
the other one was uh this paper called
GRPO done right which actually just
removed
the normalization term.
I'll go down that.
Cool. So this was last time and last
time what we said right before starting
the reasoning class was to enumerate the
strength and the weaknesses of vanilla
LLMs.
So last lecture was all about focusing
on how we can improve the limited
reasoning capabilities of vanilla LLMs.
And in this lecture what we will do is
two things. So the first one is see how
we can connect our LLM to the ever
evolving knowledge base
and in particular see how we can um have
access to the latest information.
And then the second one is how our LLM
can help us perform actions and we will
see this with Shervin uh with things
like tool calling and agentic workflows.
Cool. So with that let's start with the
first one and let's start with this
method called rag that you may have
heard.
So
let's suppose you have a model that you
have trained
uh but the problem is that the
pre-training data on which you have
trained your model is let's say a month
a month ago let's suppose
now let's suppose you want to prompt
your model about the winner of the
elections that happened a couple of
weeks ago. Well, your model will not be
able to respond to you or it will output
the incorrect answer because up until
now our LLM does not have any link to
outside sources. It only relies on the
knowledge that it has acquired during
training. So the response that it will
give us will only be based on the data
that has been trained up until the
cutoff which is a month ago in this
example.
And so we have this big limitation which
is our LLM only knows about things that
is it has been trained on. And you will
see that all the models out there. So
here I have an example with OpenAI GPT5.
So if you look at their model cards,
they always have these knowledge cutoff
dates that is written somewhere. And in
the case for instance of GPT5, the
knowledge cut off date is September
30th,
2024.
Which means that if you ask it in a very
naive way, anything that happen after
that like the base model will not be
able to answer you as is.
Well, you might you may tell me why not
just uh continue training your model uh
on you know data that happened after
that. Well, the problem with that
actually there are several problems with
this. So the first problem is that it's
very tricky to change the knowledge of
an LLM without causing regression on
other things. So this is typically a
task that people they try to avoid
doing. And the second thing is it's not
very practical because you may very well
have use cases that require you to
fine-tune this model.
So let's suppose you have a use case
one. You fine-tune from this model and
then somehow you want to update the
weights of your model to inject some
knowledge. Well, you somehow will have
to do that for all the use cases that
you are doing which basically adds a lot
of overhead for you and just uh you know
adds a lot of maintenance.
So people they typically prefer to not
do additional training to inject
knowledge. So one idea can be to somehow
take your prompt and just add anything
that happens after the cut off date
as a way for your model to just know
what happened.
Well,
the problem with that naive approach is
that as you know context length length
is limited and so typically models have
on the order of magnitude of oh of
hundreds of thousands of tokens in
context length.
Do you know what that is roughly like
what is this roughly equal to?
Yes. So one token is equal to four
characters. So like using this like
rough approximation
uh hundreds of thousands of tokens is
roughly like hundreds of pages like
something like a very big book. So so
it's not it's not I mean it's it's big
but it's not enough for us to go in that
very naive route. So
um so again going back to GPT5 uh so if
you go to the model card you have the
knowledge cutoff date which is uh
September 2024. You also have the
context window and in this case it's
400,000
tokens.
U okay so let's suppose you actually uh
context is not a problem. It's actually
unlimited.
Let's imagine we actually put everything
in the context. Well, the problem then
is that people noticed that if you feed
a lot of irrelevant information to your
LLM,
the performance of the LLM will actually
degrade.
Meaning that if for instance you ask it
about I guess who was the winner of the
last elections and then you you feed it
a bunch of information that are not
relevant your LLM will tend to be
confused
and so people have run this test that's
called the needle in a haststack test
where the idea is
you give a big prompt to your LLM
which is your haststack
and you place a fact in the prompt and
you ask your model what that fact was.
So the idea is for your LLM to know I
guess among that huge prompt where is
the relevant information which is the
needle. And so when people have tried
doing this for several uh length of
prompts and tried different positions of
where to put the fact, they have seen
that
the length of the prompt and the
position at which you put the fact are
both important.
So here uh on the slide we have a heat
map um that was performed for GPT4 which
was I guess one or two years ago and uh
what the person did was place the fact
at different places in the document. So
this is document depth and the x-axis is
the length of your prompt.
And what we saw was that for prompts
that exceeded a certain amount of
tokens, the LLM actually had trouble
retrieving the correct piece of
information.
Um, and in particular, it had trouble
doing so when the fact was somewhere in
the first half of the prompt.
Um so this just tells us that you know
even if [snorts] like let's say our
context length was unlimited
we would still have a problem by just
going through that naive approach.
So that's another reason. Okay. So now
let's suppose context length is
unlimited. Let's suppose the problem
that I mentioned is not a problem. Well
the other problem is that you pay
So in particular, these calls, these LLM
calls, they are per token.
So the bigger your input prompt, the
more you will pay. So you have an
incentive to not put too much in your
prompt just from that standpoint.
And so for instance again going back to
GP5
uh order of magnitude is somewhere
around a dollar per million token. So I
guess it's not that expensive but it can
add up if you do that for all your
prompts.
So for all these reasons, I hope I
convinced you that we need a more clever
approach where instead of putting all
the new information all at once in the
prompt, what we do is we only somehow
find the relevant information and put
that in the prompt.
So that is the idea behind rag. Rag
stands for retrieval augmented
generation.
And the idea here is to augment the
prompt
with relevant information.
And here I put uh relevant in both uh
and this is the I guess the core part of
this technique is how can we get only
the relevant part in the prompt. So we
will see that in a second. So just at a
very high level. So you have let's say a
question as input. So in this case who
was the winner of let's say the local
election. The idea here is to somehow
fetch the correct or the relevant piece
of information and then augment that
here in order to output your answer.
So that's the rough idea.
So does this uh method make sense so
far?
Yeah. Okay. Cool. So that is the idea
behind rag and now we're going to go
into more details.
Um so what I mentioned is the rough
idea. Um and here I just want to
emphasize on the three main steps of
rag. So first one is you have your
prompt and you somehow want to retrieve
a relevant piece of information that
will help you in answering your prompt.
So here the first step is to retrieve
relevant documents and so you can think
of your prompt as being one entity and
then you can have some other uh space
which maybe like I don't know knowledge
base where all your documents live and
so the idea is to somehow fetch the
relevant documents.
So this is the retrieve step. The second
step is once you have fetched the
relevant information, you augment your
prompt. So you take that retrieved info,
you just put it in your prompt and then
uh ask the question. So in the local
election example, it's as if I was
saying who is the winner of this
election and then I retrieve the
relevant piece of information and now
the prompt becomes um who is the winner
of this election and by the way uh this
election was held blah blah blah and
this was the winner and this is what
we're feeding to our LLM.
So in other words, we're giving the
answer in the prompt
and the third step is to feed that
prompt to the LM to generate the
response. Yeah.
>> Yeah, exactly. So the question is uh you
may very well somehow do a bad job at
retrieval stage. So yes um so this is
why the retrieval stage is so important
and we're going to focus on what we can
do to make sure that one part like does
well.
Um so yeah uh we'll see how we can
evaluate um I guess our our setup and
different methods. But when we talk
about rag, we're mainly focusing on
making the retrieval part as good as it
can.
Cool. And I just want to emphasize once
again on why it's called rag. So you
have retrieve,
augment, generate
rag.
Cool. And as you pointed out the first
step which is the retrieval step is very
important which is why we'll spend a
little bit of time over there.
So I guess the first step is for us to
somehow
clean the set of documents that we may
need.
So I said you know uh we may um want to
look into outside information but we
need to somehow uh sort that order that
put that somewhere and this whole thing
is usually called a knowledge base.
So in order to form our knowledge base
what we do is typically collect the set
of documents that are or may be useful
and once we do that what we do is we
divide them into what we call chunks.
So a chunk is you can think of it as a
subset of the document which has a given
maximum length which is uh measured in
number of tokens which is typically on
the order of hundreds of tokens.
And the idea here is you know whenever
you hear retrieval you should think
about embeddings.
And here what we do is
we compute embeddings corresponding to
each of these chunks.
Now when you create your knowledge base
there are a few hyperparameters that you
need to tweak.
So the first one uh obviously is the
size of the embedding. So typically you
would want a bigger size if let's say
your documents are maybe more nuanced,
more complex.
But then if you have like a higher size
uh maybe it will take more space, maybe
you'll have more computation at
inference time. So I guess it's a
trade-off. You don't necessarily want
too big of a of an embedding size. So
here typical embedding sizes are on the
order of thousands. So for instance like
1,500 something like this.
So then you have the chunk size. Chunk
size is how big your little pieces here
are. So you don't want them to be too
small because otherwise the text may be
out of context. You don't want it to be
too large because maybe the embedding
will not represent in a meaningful way
what is inside. So again, it's a
trade-off. But typically people they
choose a chunk size of around 500 tokens
like on the order of hundreds of tokens.
And then you also have a oh yeah you
have a question. Yeah.
So the question is do you train an
embedding model for this? So you have
two choices. Either you can use a
pre-trained embedding model which people
typically do or you can train your own.
We will see that in a bit more detail in
a few slides.
So the question is what is the purpose
of the embedded model? So we will see
this in a second but long story short it
tries to represent chunks such that it
achieves your end goal which is to fetch
relevant documents.
So we will see a little bit how they're
trained but this is uh the general idea.
Cool. Um so that's this and then we have
a third hyperparameter
which is how much overlap you want to
have in between your chunks.
So here
um when you do the division uh you know
you uh like in a very naive way you have
everything be like independent no
overlap in between but typically you
have some part that is from the previous
chunk that is relevant to understand the
current chunk which is why we want to
have some overlap and which is why
people they typically also have that. So
it's typically in the low hundreds of
tokens.
Cool. So let's suppose you have your
knowledge base. Now the question is
given a prompt how can you retrieve
relevant documents
and the answer to that is we typically
proceed in two steps.
So I'm not sure if any of you has
background in recommendation systems or
search does any Yeah. So the methods
we're seeing here are very similar to
that space. So I guess people in the LLM
community they have borrowed ideas and
just leverage some techniques that we
have over there. And this is typically a
setting that we'll also have for
recommendation problems.
So we have two stages.
So the first stage is typically called
candidate retrieval.
And the goal here is to go from a set of
many many many chunks and filter it down
to a much smaller set of potentially
relevant candidates.
So during that stage, what we're trying
to do is to somehow maximize recall.
just do a rough operation
so that we get as many potentially
relevant candidates as possible.
And then we have a a second stage which
is sometimes optional, but this stage is
to really make sure we have the top
documents being the really the relevant
ones. And this one is called ranking.
So the idea here is
based on the list of potentially
relevant documents to really rank them
in a way that really the relevant ones
come at the top and so on.
And typically during that stage, we're
going to use a model, a method that's
going to be a bit more compute inensive
because we have a much smaller set of
candidates to rank compared to the first
one.
So going back to your question on how do
we want our embeddings to be. So here it
will really impact uh the first stage
and we will see that in a second, but
the second stage is also quite
important.
Cool. So far so good. Is everyone uh
clear with the two-stage approach
approach?
Yep. Yep.
Yeah.
Very good question. So the question is
do we chunk things in a naive way as in
we just go with the number of tokens
regardless of what happens. So it's a
great question and the answer is that we
will see some extensions that will
mitigate the problem of when you chunk
it in a way that does not make sense in
a naive way you want to somehow put that
into context and we will see a method
that does that. So in a few slides we
will see that.
Um but I think your question is also a
great question because depending on the
kind of document that we have like for
instance if we have uh I don't know like
a JSON file or a markdown or like
depending on the kind of file that you
need to chunk you also need to be aware
of the structure that is within those
files. So there is also some nuance
there that we will not go into details
but I just want to call that out
but yeah great question.
Any other questions?
Okay cool. So now that we're clear on
the two main stages of retrieval we're
going to focus on each one of these
steps.
So as I mentioned the first step is
candidate retrieval.
So here what we want is among that
potentially huge knowledge base to
somehow filter it down to let's say over
100 potentially relevant candidates.
So here what we do is well we will
leverage the embeddings that we um I
guess computed during the knowledge base
initialization
and
we will try to fetch
potentially relevant candidates by doing
a semantic similarity search.
So do you recall how we compare
embeddings?
Yes. Yes. So cosign similarity is
typically one way one good way to
compare embeddings. So the idea here is
to represent our query with an
embedding.
We already have
embeddings of all our chunks. So the
idea here is
to somehow find the most relevant chunks
by doing this similarity search and
filtering out the ones that come at the
top.
So the idea here is you have your query,
you have your chunk both of them, you
find an embedding
and then you perform a similarity
operation which is most of the time
cosign similarity
and you obtain a similarity score.
So the idea here is you just just keep
top I don't know 100 and you go with
that.
So I just want to call out that there is
some complexity in that stage because
your knowledge base can potentially be
huge.
So what people do is typically use what
we call approximate nearest neighbor
methods.
So you may have heard of some libraries
[music] that do that. So typically this
is something that will be relevant here.
We're not going to go into details, but
I just want to call that out. So here,
the idea here is that
when you build your knowledge base, you
somehow partition the embeddings in a
way that will avoid like make you avoid
doing like just a naive linear search.
So that's the idea. But uh you you may
see some techniques uh like ANN
techniques approximate near nearest
nearest neighbor techniques and these
are typically happening here.
So another thing that I want to point
out is
a name of the architecture that we
typically use here that you may also
hear
and for that we need to recall that
these embeddings they're actually
obtained by passing them through a
model. So typically encoder only.
So you may hear the term by encoder and
this one refers to the fact that we are
passing the query through an encoder and
then passing the chunk through an
encoder. So both of them are independent
and we're comparing the embeddings
and uh yeah so this is another question
I wanted to ask you but I guess I didn't
get the chance to but um so if you
remember I think lecture two or three we
had seen the birds model
and so typically you would have
something like a birdlike model that you
would use to um encode these documents.
So going back to your question, how do
you compute these embeddings? So there
is a a paper that I highly recommend
reading actually that's called sentence
BERT.
And so that paper explains so it's first
of all it's an extension of BERT as the
name suggests and it's an extension that
allows you to compute an embedding per
let's say sequence for your query for
your document
that is tailored
to be used for similarity search
purposes.
So the idea here is to have a loss
function that will incentivize having a
high cosine similarity for relevant
entities and low cosine similarity for
entities that are not relevant.
So yeah, so feel free to check that
paper out uh if you know birds which I I
know right now you do. Uh it's quite
easy to read. So yeah, highly recommend.
So far so good.
Yeah. Yep.
So the question is what is the default
way to compute the similarity? So yes
it's cosign similarity but again you
will see in different implementations
that people can use other distances and
I would encourage you to think about how
they relate to one another. So you will
see for instance the L2 distance but
then if everything has a norm of one
there's a lot of simplifications that
can happen. So you may see some variance
but I would say they're all more or less
cosign similarities.
Yeah great question.
Cool. So we're still at the candidate
retrieval stage and what we saw was one
way of retrieving documents from a
similarity sorry from a semantic
similarity standpoint. So by the way
what does semantic similarity mean? It
means finding documents or finding
entities that have the same meaning or
that are relevant.
But in the way that we compute these
embeddings, we're not enforcing any kind
of uh keyword match.
Like when we re when we retrieve
documents in this way, it can very well
be that the documents that are matched,
they do not have any word in common, but
they mean the same.
Well, sometimes
you want to ensure that your what you're
looking for, what you're searching for
is exactly containing the keywords that
is in your prompt.
And in that case you would want to have
a second way of doing things. So you may
have seen BM25
out there. So BF20 BM25 is a relevant
score that is actually a huristic score.
It is based on some function of the
overlap
between what is in your query and what
is in your document.
And so that one is actually quite handy
for cases where you have a query where
you absolutely want to have documents
that contain keywords of this query.
So here I have an example that I
actually passed super briefly for the
previous one and we will come back to
it. Uh but let's suppose we have let's
say two teddy bears. One is named cuddly
and the other one is named huggy. So
what you want is to figure out where is
cuddly. So this is your query.
So if you use BM25
well the answers that you you're going
to get are
by definition going to contain some
overlap of words that were in your
query. And so here you will have let's
say uh documents that contain let's say
where cuddly is. But if let's say you
you only used this semantic similarity
search you would not have that
guarantee.
you would only have documents that are
kind of semantically similar and those
are not
they are not guaranteed to contain
keywords of your prompt and so just just
to illustrate that. So here huggy and
cuddly they they can be thought of you
know semantically similar. So you you
will probably not have cuddly. I mean
you may not necessarily have cuddly in
there
just to illustrate that and that is the
reason why nowadays what people do is to
look at the use cases that they have and
think about whether having some heristic
as well in the relevant score is useful
for their use case. So some people they
go with the hybrid combination
of this embedding based search and the
huristic based search. So some
combination of uh embeddings and BM25 in
which case you may have even more
relevant documents depending on your use
case.
Does that make sense? Yeah.
So now I'll come back to what you
mentioned about whether cutting chunks
in a naive way will necessarily lead you
to things that are coherent. Well,
you're completely right. Sometimes you
will not. Um but before we answer this
question, we actually are going to
address another concern
which is that typically
when people want
to ask about something in their LLM,
the query that they input is of a
different nature
compared to what is in the knowledge
base. So your query is typically going
to be maybe something uh short, maybe a
question,
but what is in your documents is
typically going to be, you know, longer.
These are like sentences and sentences.
So if you really think about it,
if you use the same encoder
to embed your query and to embed your
documents,
well, these two embeddings, they're not
super comparable
because one is for a question and the
other one is for a document.
So there's one extension that tries to
mitigate that issue and uh I linked the
paper down there. It's called the
height.
So what it does is instead of computing
the embedding
related to the prompt, it will first
generate a fake document. So it's just
an LM call, a fake document based on
that prompt
and then embeds
that fake document to find relevant
chunks.
So it may or may not work. It's not used
all the time by everyone. So I would say
just something that is good to try to
see if that that works. But this is one
way of mitigating this. Another way it
could be to simply have encoders that
are specifically trained to encode the
query on one side and encode the
documents on the other side.
So in other words to not use the same
encoder.
People typically don't do that just
because of maintenance purposes but this
could also be another solution.
Okay. So now finally going to your your
question regarding how we can make sense
of these chunks. If they are taken out
of context they may not make sense.
And so here the idea here is to prepend
some piece of text that just sums up
what you need to know in order to
understand that chunk.
So here the idea is that you have all
your documents. Let's say you have one
document that you divide it into n
chunks.
The idea here is instead of considering
these chunks separately,
you're going to
compute some kind of context that is
relevant to each chunk and that is based
on the whole document.
So how are you going to do that? So well
it's again an LLM call. So what you do
is typically uh have let's say the whole
document and then you have the chunk
that you want to contextualize and you
ask your model well please give me a
short 16 context to just make sense of
that chunk
and now you may tell me well that's a
lot of LM calls you have potentially a
lot of chunks and that's just going to
be very pricey. Well, there's one
strategy to make this less expensive.
And I'm not sure if you've heard that uh
option. It's called prompt caching.
So now that you know very well how LLM
work, you know like typically these are
decoder only and so on. So you know that
if
you use
the same prefix
for all your prompts,
well it's going to be the same
computations that you just do again and
again and again.
So the idea here is you just do it once
and you save all the relevant
activations
and instead of computing them again
you're just going to look them up just
do a lookup and then decode the rest.
Does that does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Um the question is activation from a
language model. Yes. Because when you
feed a prompt to your model and you ask
it to generate a response,
what the model needs to do is well to
take all this like input and then
compute the activations of all the
layers and then have uh you know for the
generation process to have uh this
attention across all these other
components. Well, given that it's
decoder only, meaning it's only left to
right,
the thing that you input, if it's the
same, then it will lead to the same
activations.
Yeah.
The question is, what if you have a
closed model? where prompt caching and
I'm going to just talk about this in
just one slide is an option that these
uh like closed models or providers
offer. And what they tell you is well
this is the same prefix for all your
prompts. So what we're going to do is
we're just going to make it cheaper for
you.
So if you look at the model pricing
page,
you will see that there is a price
for regular inputs. So inputs that are
not cached and then you have the price
per cached input token. And here you see
for the let's say open model it's
one10enth
of the price. So I guess what do I want
to tell you by this? Well, just try to
be smart with the prompts and try to
gather all the things that are likely to
be repeated across prompts in the
beginning so that you can uh leverage
this nice uh uh percentage of
that make sense.
Okay, cool.
Great. So up until now we have seen how
we can go from potentially thousands or
even like let's say millions of chunks
up to uh or down to uh let's say
hundreds of potentially relevant chunks.
Now what we want to do is to sort them
in a more meaningful way. And the second
part is more optional because maybe
sometimes this first cut that we've done
may be good enough. But I guess this
second step is about being more
intentional in how we give the final
score to be able to really like select
the final let's say top K chunks.
So this second stage is called ranking
or even reranking.
reranking because I guess with the first
step you already have some kind of
ranking. So we're reranking
and what we're doing is instead of using
this very quick operation similarity
operation between embeddings that we've
computed,
we're going to use something that is
maybe a bit more sophisticated.
So instead of considering the query and
the chunk separately,
what we're going to do is to actually
put them both in the encoder, both of
them, and have a relevant score out of
that.
So the reason why it's maybe a little
bit more meaningful to do it this way is
that you have a model that takes a look
at both your query and your chunk at the
same time and gives you gives you a
score.
Whereas in the first step you had one
embedding for the query and one
embedding for the chunk which didn't
have that like interaction that a model
could capture.
And you will also see out there that
this setup is called cross encoder setup
because you have both your inputs
fed to your encoder. So there's like
some cross interactions.
So if you remember the first approach is
a by encoder kind of setup and this one
is a cross encoder.
Yeah, the question is you will actually
compute the attention between the two.
Yes,
absolutely.
And uh here I mean um sentence bird
there they have a lot of uh good
documents. So I highly recommend just
reading their docs there at the bottom
of the slide.
Cool. Well, you do that uh on all your
uh potentially relevant chunks. So you
have uh this uh score that is computed
for each of these chunk with the prompts
and then you finally obtain the ranking.
And now the question is are you happy
with the ranking?
And in order to answer that question,
you need to have a way to quantify your
performance.
And that's why we're going to see in the
next five minutes what are the metrics
that we typically use to do that. So
again this is very similar to you know
if you do search or recommendation. So
in case you have a background there you
will see some commonalities.
So here's the setup.
You have a bunch of chunks.
You do this first and second step
and at the end of the day you will have
k chunks that will come at the top that
you will qualify as being relevant
and you want to compare that with
respect to
actually relevant chunks. So you can
think of it as you know you have label
like same as in binary classification.
So you have relevant and not relevant
and you predict some that are relevant
and you want to know how well you're
doing.
So this is the setup.
Well, when it comes to ranking,
you need to somehow incorporate this
information of how high in the ranking
you've put stuff.
So here let's suppose that you have
ranked these n chunks from most
important to least important. So let's
suppose you have like first, second, uh
third and so on and so forth.
And you only care about the first K
because in the rack setting you
typically retrieve the top K that are
relevant and you put all these top K in
your prompt.
Well, the first metric that you will
likely use is called NDCG.
So, it's a lot of letters. I'm going to
just explain what that means. So, NDCG
tries to quantify how good your ranking
is by taking into consideration
where you ranked relevant documents.
So you have this formula that may seem
scary, but it's actually quite simple
what it's trying to do. So it's trying
to
incentivize the score to be higher if
you're ranking the relevant documents
closer to the first position.
So what it does is it is a sum over the
first k positions that you've ranked and
it is looking at whether what you've
ranked for each of these positions is
relevant or not.
So for instance it checks the first
position. Okay, first position is it
relevant or not? So relevance if it's
relevant it's one. So it's one over some
quantity that is a function of the rank
and it does that for all the ranks.
So this score score will be higher if
you rank relevant documents high.
So that's basically the goal of this
metric. Um so this part is the
discounted cumulative gain. So it's
cumulative grain because you're looking
at
basically if you had relevant documents
in your first k positions which is the
cumulative part
it's discounted because it's better for
you to have a relevant document in
position one let's say than position k
and you can see that in the denominator.
Now why do we say NDCG like what is the
normalization part? Well, this metric
can take a lot of different values
depending on how many relevant documents
there are. So what people do is they
compute the quote unquote ideal or
optimal or upper bound DCG that you can
get for a given query.
And they call that ideal DCG.
and they just normalize DCG over IDCG.
So the reason why they do that is
they want you to score a score of one if
you are matching the optimal ranking.
They want they basically want to make
the score meaningful.
So does this make sense?
Yeah.
So, so the question is how do they
compute the relevance uh score? So, you
can think of step one and step two as
being a two-step process
for you to say which documents you're
saying are relevant. So at the end of
this two two-step stage, the ones that
you say are relevant are here.
Now you typically have a score for each
retrieved chunk. So you're going to sort
these chunks.
You're going to sort them by the score
in a descending order.
And the relevance here that you're going
to use is the actual label. So is the
chunk actually
relevant or not? So you're going to look
at your k retrieved chunks and you're
going to ask yourself, okay, is the
first chunk actually relevant? So you
have a label? You know which ones are
relevant, which ones are not? And these
ones are going to be the ones you will
use in the formula.
Yes, that's the ground truth. Exactly.
Yeah.
Cool. Does that make sense?
Yeah. Okay, great. Uh, so you have a
bunch of other metrics. You have another
one that's called the reciprocal rank.
So this one is much simpler. Uh, it
takes the
uh inverse of the rank of the highest
rank
of all the relevant documents. So if
let's suppose in your first in your top
K documents let's suppose the first
relevant document let's say comes at
rank number two then rank will be equal
to two. So it basically does not care
about
uh any relevant documents that are
passed that first relevant document. So
this is just like a simpler metric that
typically correlates well. So that's why
people use it.
And then of course I mean you're
familiar with the classic classification
metrics recall and precision. So if you
remember if you have two classes you
have the positive class you have the
negative class. So recall what it does
is it takes a look at all the actually
positive observations
and it tries to ask itself among all
these actually positive samples which
are the ones that you actually predicted
positive
that's a recall that you all know and
there is a I guess a ranking equivalent
which is out of all the documents that
are relevant actually relevant. So this
is like your positive class
which are the ones that you actually
predicted as being relevant.
So this is basically which ones are in
the top K.
And similarly you also have the
precision equivalent. So if you remember
precision is out of all the ones that
you have predicted to be positives.
How many of them are actually positive?
So this is the equivalent here. So which
are the ones that you've predicted to be
positive? So which are the ones that you
have selected in your top k
and among those ones which ones are
actually positive. So which one are
actually relevant?
Does that make sense?
So I guess uh these four metrics so
NDCG, MRR, precision at K, recall at K,
you will see this see this in a bunch of
papers. So I just highly recommend you
just get familiar with their ideas maybe
with the formula and uh these would be
the ones that you would use to quantify
whether your retriever is doing a good
job or not. So you have a bunch of
benchmarks out there. So there is one
that is actually quite popular. It's
called massive text embedding benchmark.
So if you want to test your retriever if
uh it performs well or not, you would
typically uh take it and then just
evaluate it on that benchmark and then
have all these metrics computed and then
if you have like different solutions you
would typically compare this metric.
And with that, I guess we uh I guess
hopefully have a better sense of how to
build a rack system and specifically how
to have a good retriever. So we have
just [snorts] maybe one more minute. Uh
is there any questions on that first
part?
>> Yep.
So the question is so for the reranking
we're using an encoder that will output
the relevant score. So we will typically
train a model that does that. Um so
there are typically I don't know I
believe there are some pre-trained ones
but out there you you can very well have
your custom one. Um, so yes, so that
model will typically be a bit more
sophisticated compared to the first step
because here you can afford to spend
more time to produce that score because
you're operating out of let's say of
hundreds possible candidates as opposed
to let's say O of much more like
millions or hundreds of thousands. So
yeah, so that's the idea.
Yep.
So the question is uh how about training
with contrastive loss? So here this is a
detail we will not uh I guess um cover
here but uh yeah in order to train these
models you'll have a bunch of different
uh types of loss function. So I highly
recommend you read the espert paper
because in that paper there are several
loss functions that the paper tries to
compare and this is one of them. So uh
yeah, so that's a great question. I
highly recommend reading the expert
paper for that.
Cool. With that, I'll give it to
Shervin. Thank you.
So thanks a lot for covering uh the rag
methodology. So now we arrive at my
favorite part of the lecture. Um, we're
going to see tool calling and the
agentic world and we're going to see how
much more powerful your LLMs are going
to become just in a second.
So, what Ashin just mentioned is how you
would deal with incorporating data that
is not structured as part of your uh
prompts to the LLM. And now we're going
to see what we could do more in the case
the data that we want to inject is
structured. So in the case of rag, you
have documents with words and words and
words and you just want to fetch the
relevant documents to answer your
prompt. But here let's suppose that you
have some structure that determines
uh input outputs in uh in your data. So
typically you could represent it maybe
as a table. So you have uh separate
columns and then depending on the value
of uh given columns you have a given
output.
So we could probably reframe that setup
into a function setup. So we c we
mentioned tool calling and then this is
this rephrasing is called a function
calling. So let's um suppose that you
get this relationship between input and
output through a function for the rest
rest rest rest rest rest rest rest rest
rest of this part and then here if I had
to transpose what the result of a given
ID and field and other arguments would
look like you could interpret it as a
function with these as arguments and the
output would be simply what you have as
an output to the function
And um in the world of tool calling and
function calling very often times you're
going to see that LLMs tend to use
Python as a language just because it's
so simple to read. Uh so this is what
we're going to use as an example as
well. But there is nothing that ties us
to Python necessarily. So you could well
have tool calling in other languages. Uh
but yeah just as a note. Any questions
on the setup?
Okay, awesome.
Um, so there is nothing controversial
about tool calling, but I'm going to
still state a full definition to make
sure that we're on the same page.
So I was browsing here and there and
then try to find an authorative source
and this website uh like on IBM there is
an article that defines that tries to
define what tool calling is. So I'm
going to anchor on their definition from
now on. Uh so I'm going to read out
loud. So tool calling allows autonomous
systems to complete complex tasks by
dynamically accessing and may act upon
external resources.
So the things that I want you to get
from that are two things. So first you
have the notion of completing some task.
So you're given an input and you you
have to complete some task and then uh
the reliance potentially on external
resources.
So it doesn't have to be external. You
don't have to rely on external
resources, but this is one potential
property that can help you um fill the
gap that Afin was mentioning at the
beginning of the lecture regarding
filling uh the knowledge gap that your
pre-trained LLM has. So, we're going to
see examples in a few minutes regarding
what that could mean. But, uh yeah, this
is one u like magical part of it.
Okay, great.
And just to make these uh statements
very grounded in a real life
applications, let's just walk through
what would a tool call give us uh in the
case of a very specific example. So
let's suppose you love teddy bears.
You're currently, you know, here at
Stanford and you want a teddy bear near
you. You know what? If you pull your
phone out and you just ask, you know,
find a teddy bear near me. Well, your
current LLM without any tools would not
know uh you know some real life or like
real time update of uh of you know
availability of teddy bears near you. So
it would probably answer you something
in the flavor of you know I don't know
or you know not sure. And I just want to
say that with the use of tools, uh,
let's see how we could get to a stage
where we can inject the information that
is necessary for the LLM to know how to
respond to your query.
And the goal of the next few minutes is
going to be for us to figure out both
what we could do uh like what we could
inject in the preamble of the LLM and
what would be the steps that we could go
through in order to complete such a
request.
Does that make sense so far?
Yep.
So the question is are those function
APIs premputed? So that's a great
question. So yes, you define them
beforehand. You have some API and we're
going to see that in a second. They're
not LLM generated on the fly.
Y
Okay, great. Any other questions on the
setup?
So I know it will be a lot lot to take
in. So
yep. Okay, great. So in order to be
grounded in real life, let's take a full
example of what a function definition
could be. So in the case of finding a
teddy bear, you could imagine a function
definition that is called find teddy
bear and depending on your location
calls some API and retrieves potential
candidates.
So I'm going to go through the uh main
characteristics of what a function call
contains and link it to the definition.
So you have okay so first of all when we
want to display such an API to the model
you need to document it uh its input and
output in order for the model to know
what this function is for. So typically
uh the description that you have in
example of Python under a given function
would be crucial for the model to know
what it is about.
And then
um we saw in the definition of tool call
that we uh that we just gave that we
have the ability to make backend calls.
And this is exactly what we would need
to do in the case of finding uh like
teddy bears around you. you would need
to query some API to retrieve available
teddy bears and based on your location
return the nearest ones. So this is
exactly what this um what this function
implementation is doing
and uh and as um like it returns
something that is well structured. So
you see uh maybe it's it's small from
where where you are but you have some uh
class definition that puts some
structure into the output and makes it
interpretable.
And we're going to see very soon that
this output is going to be what the
model will anchor on in order to give
its final response.
Okay, great.
And one other thing I will say is all of
this that we see here is what you have
implemented.
You will not see all of this. Uh you
know if you are an LLM, you will not see
all of this. All you care about as an
LLM is the function API, the input and
output as well as the main lines of
documentations. So all these
implementation details, you're going to
have it on your uh codebase, but the LLM
is not going to see it.
Okay, great. So now let's go u step by
step into how we could make make this
work.
So uh the first stage is uh as you ask a
question that is related to your
function, you would insert at the
beginning of your preamble the function
API and as I mentioned without its
implementation. So you just have u like
the function itself and then a full
documentation.
So here uh you would want the LLM based
on your user query to feed the right
arguments to your function. So to your
point the goal of the LLM here is not
going to be to infer any of the
functions implementations rather only
what arguments we should put to it. Yep.
Yep.
So the question is how do you even train
this? So we're going to see uh that in
just a few slides. Yeah. So great point.
That's the next question u you know we
need to ask ourselves. Yeah.
Yeah. So we're going to see how we train
this. Um so but here um let's say it has
been trained uh the LLM would have from
its context probably our localization
because let's say you have activated
your uh you know location permissions
and your LLM knows where you are so it
knows you are at Stanford and these
would be the coordinates being fed to
your LLM
and then the second stage is to actually
do that function call. So nothing it has
nothing to do with LLMs. You just take
your function your argument and you
execute that
and you get some answer and the answer
as we mentioned is structured in a way
that's understandable. So in that
function implementation you return some
object that informs characteristics
about the return teddy bear. So for
example you have its name, maybe
location and so on.
and you feed that response back to the
LLM in order to get a final response. So
when you ask to the LLM a given
question, you don't want to have this uh
you know JSON like response but rather a
response in natural language. And this
exactly is the motivation for that last
stage.
So, I'm going to pause here for a second
and check that this three-stage
mechanism makes sense to everyone.
Yeah. Okay. Great.
And
and exactly what you were mentioning
here is going to be the next focus. How
do you even train that? So, okay. So,
let me ask you this question.
If you were to train an LLM to use this
tool, what steps would you need to focus
on?
Right? So the answer is you're going to
feed the API implementation. Yes.
So you would need the first LLM call to
be somehow recognizing the pattern of
the function implementation and the
query and link it to the um the
arguments that you would put in your
function. So yeah, great. So tool
prediction
and do you need a second set of SFT
pairs?
So you have this last stage that is
still LLM driven where you have your
tool answer and you need to output a
final response.
So
you might say, okay, hey, the LLM has
seen a bunch of structured data and
knows how to put into words things that
it sees, which is a fair point, but
usually you might want your responses to
be formatted a given way. So you might
want to also have SFT pairs that do this
mapping the way you want it to.
So this is why you typically have these
two SFT pairs. And if I have to be a bit
more precise, the second pair isn't just
mapping the JSON response to the final
response. It's actually linking all the
conversation history so far. So that it
knows that the initial query was someone
in search of a teddy bear. It knows
there has been a tool call and it knows
that the results correspond to that tool
call. So it would be a slightly longer
input uh in this SFT pair.
Does that make sense?
Okay, great. Yep.
Yeah. Uh so great point. So the question
is what if we have more tools? Do we
need like some tool selection or like
more examples? So this is a great topic.
We're going to see it uh like in in in a
few slides. Yeah. So it's slightly more
complex way of doing things. But if you
want a very quick answer, if you go the
SFT way, you could show multi- uh tool
kinds of inputs. So you could include
all of that in your SFT data sets. But
we're going to see the topic of tool
selection very soon.
Great. Any other questions?
Okay. Awesome. So uh so this is what I
just mentioned. Yeah, the conversation
history so far is always what you get as
part of the inputs and then the output
is what you would want the LLM to
predict at that given stage. And since
you're doing SFT here, you don't have
just one but multiple such examples and
you would want your examples to be
varied and representing the typical user
distribution.
So I was asking find a bear near me and
this example showed to the model how you
could ground the information of location
based on the user's location even though
you didn't give it. And in these other
examples, you could give uh the model
other kinds of instructions like
directly saying uh I want a bear at that
location to teach the model to look at
like to ground the argument at different
places. And you could expand this set by
also uh varying the kind of input so it
doesn't have to be worried that way. You
could do it multi-turn maybe in the
middle of a conversation you ask for a
bear and so on. Yeah.
Okay, great. But this is not the only
way of uh of training a model to do so.
So these days, LLMs become more and more
powerful in their reasoning. And the
kind of data they are trained at
pre-training and initial instruction
tuning is typically these kinds of code
data. So at the end of it, they know how
to manipulate Python codes very well. So
you might ask yourself, is it really
needed for me to teach the model how to
map a query to a function to a function
call? And that is a very uh interesting
observation.
And you see these days that you can
forgo
specific SFT training and try to get
around it with only training.
So here
instead of um you know writing SFT and
then retraining the model, we're going
to see that you could actually replace
it with only an explanation.
And does anyone have an idea of how we
could even come up with such an
explanation?
So let's say I have a new tool. I have
the API. I want my model to use it.
How would you go around it?
Yep, there's a great point. So, one
method could be fshot learning. You just
uh show in the context window um samples
of input output. This this is a great
point. You could definitely do that. And
this is typically one accepted practice.
Um but if I if I told you that fshot
learning has um challenges when it comes
to generalization because you would need
to give specific points as input output.
So it might fit to some cases and not
necessarily generalize to the whole span
of human language. Um you know is there
another way you you could go around it?
Yeah. So the the answer is ask it to do
reasoning. You know, great points and
writing a prompt that does the reasoning
in a way that makes sense is very hard.
So in practice, you wouldn't write it
yourself. You would take these SFT
pairs. Okay, so these are the behavior
that you want to enforce and you could
use it as some evaluation set. So you
could say okay if I do if I ask this
question I want that tool call and you
have a set of pairs and you could run
whatever you have so far in terms of
explanation.
You evaluate these prompts against the
evaluation set. So you have some wins
and losses. Maybe find a bear in Paris
doesn't work well. Some other prompts
do. So you have a list of um of like
each sample with like a score and you
could feed it back to a reasoning model
typically to do the explanation writing
for you. So yeah, this is a trick to
you know help you avoid doing that hard
work. basically showing the model, you
know, hey, with the current prompt,
here's what we get. What would you have
changed in order to make the evaluation
results better? So, you get with that
process an iteration on the detailed
explanation. And if you have to see
results in practice, you would be
surprised at how well it does the
explanation for you. So, the takeaway
here is I do not recommend you write it
end to end. maybe just a draft and you
let some very powerful model with
excellent
knowledge of uh logic do it for you.
Yep.
>> Yep. So the question is what you just
mentioned is it training or inference.
So it's training. So you do it at the
very beginning. You want a fixed prompt
that explains to the LLM how to use it,
how to use that function. So you would
typically do that offline. offline you
iterate on the explanation that says
exactly how you use the prompt uh how
you use the function and then at
inference time you would put that fixed
explanation alongside the function API
such that for any query it knows what to
do
does that make sense
okay great
any other questions here
okay amazing
So
I just mentioned an example with teddy
bears that would be in the category of
maybeformational.
So you have um so you have a question
and you want to ask some external API to
retrieve that and you have in reality a
lot more use cases that you might see.
So when I've mentioned you have some
cutoff dates and let's say you ask your
LLM about news of the day. So you
typically wouldn't have anything that
comes from the model itself. You would
have an API that fetches it from a tool
called maybe search,
but you have also other kinds of tools
available in in the information
category. So for example, weather,
stocks, and um let's see um you know,
but you also have other categories. For
example, if you want to ask the model to
do some calculation for you,
you could let the model figure it out
with some reasoning chain. But one way
to get around it is to transform the
query into code, execute that code and
then read out the answer. So this is why
uh like tool call has a whole span of
applications in the computation.
um area. So you have calculations and uh
you have another category that we can
site here. So you can take actions on
behalf of the user. So let's say you
have a tool that sends emails. You could
ask the model to send an email for you
and it could um put the right things
into uh the header and the message body
and even hit send for you because you
have that component that interacts with
the external world as part of the as
part of the tool API.
Um yeah so these are just a few examples
but I just want to say that uh the field
of tool calling is so powerful you can
do anything you want
and
in practice exactly as you mentioned you
wouldn't have just a single tool API as
part of the uh context
you would have several ones because your
LLM is not just an LLM for finding bears
right you might want to do other things
with your LM maybe you want to hug a
teddy bear or check a teddy bear's
moods, send teddy bears a gift, you
know, and other things. So, you have a
lot more functions that might be
relevant to be added as a preamble just
because you don't know what function
would need to be used. You just need to
put all of that just in case.
So the setup is exactly the one that you
mentioned where you don't have just one
API but multiple ones.
Um does anyone see any issues by do with
doing so?
Yeah. So the suggestion is that that's a
lot of tools. Yeah. And then you're
right. So typically if you have too many
tools you have the problem that Afin
mentioned at the beginning of a needle
in a haststack where maybe some tool API
will get lost in the context and you
don't really know what to use you have a
lot of conflicting APIs maybe and we're
going to see very soon how to um kind of
overcome that issue.
Okay, great.
So I want to take a pause here and
summarize how far we've come and some of
the drawbacks that we that we have and
see together what we could do to remedy
these drawbacks.
So, first we saw that we came from an
LLM that just responded back at you with
a normal words to an LLM that can
actually interact with the outside
world, fetch real-time information or
even extend computing capabilities
um and uh and exactly like overcomes the
issue that Afin was mentioning the
knowledge cut off one in a different way
that than what rag would do. So you
could see these two methods as being
complimentary
and yeah both try to do the same thing
in some sense
but uh exactly as someone mentioned here
uh if you have more tools then your
context window might have things that it
doesn't needs and um and then if you try
to support so many cases you might end
up being mediocre at all of them.
So this is an issue and even if that
wasn't an issue, you still have the
context window that is finite. So let's
say you have uh hundreds of millions of
users that use your LLM and that want to
you to do a lot of things. You cannot
support everyone's use cases at once
just because you couldn't possibly fit
all of such tools in your context.
Yeah.
And then uh last
when I mention these tools, these are
things I hand wrote and maybe each LLM
has their own way of defining and using
tools. We're going to see if there is a
way to standardize maybe the way we
define and use tools uh later on. So do
these drawbacks make sense?
Yeah. Okay, great.
So let's move on to tool selection. Uh
so let's see what we could do in order
to make um tool use more scalable. So
I'm going to site uh here
um a technical paper from Google deep
minds uh which uses a tool selector
system. So it functions in two steps. So
first you have your query and you have a
list of tools that can be as big as you
want and that list of tools only
contains the API name and maybe one or
two words about what it does.
So you have uh like this this prompt and
the list of tools and we ask the LLM to
pick the tools that might be relevant.
So this is why the technical paper calls
this system a tool selector. You could
even see the term router um like being
pronounced in the literature. So tool
selection routing are similar concepts.
And the goal here is to restrict the
number of tools to only those that might
be useful. And in the second stage, you
take all the selected tool APIs and feed
only those to the context alongside your
query. And this is uh one way you could
take to overcome this um
this this issue of having too many tools
at once.
Is everyone convinced that tool
selection could be a good way to to fix
the problem here?
Yep.
Yeah. So, the question is, is that
basically rag? You could do it with rag,
you know, that's a great point, but it
doesn't necessarily have to. So, you
could uh have uh an LLM that does this
job just uh picking the right the right
tools and you ask some instructions to
the LLM to output the right answer. You
could definitely do it with drag. U that
that is just a great point. Yeah.
Yep. So, does it make sense to everyone?
Okay, great. And I see time is flying.
So, we're going to go very quickly on
the standardization
uh issue. So as I mentioned every tools
implementation like the way you specify
a tool implementation can be bespoke to
a given LLM and you wouldn't want that
because for every LLM you might need to
implement always the like these tools
like over and over again and duplication
is not what you want. This is why there
is a standard called MCP that I know um
no know a lot of people talk about it.
Uh so so it's something from the
anthropic team that's uh like
standardizes the way tools are exposed
to models. So it's a protocol. It's
called the model context protocol and it
defines um you know standard way of
presenting these tools. So I'm going
just to say the very uh big lines of it
where uh so you have this kind of
vocabulary as part of MCP. So you have u
an MCP server which is the instance that
serves tools. Okay. And then tools are
implementations of the functions that
you want people to use. Prompts are
sorts of templates that could show the
user how to use these tools. And then
all of these can anchor on resources
which are external
um sort of databases that you can use to
complete the task. And then an MCP
server when you use it has a onetoone
connection with a piece of
infrastructure in your LLM host that is
called MCP clients. But these are maybe
infrastructure details. Uh and I just
want to ground what I just mentioned in
reality. So we know our teddy bear loves
to read poetry. Um so in the case of
recommending a poetry book to to our
teddy bear, you could think of a MCP
server that provides tools that are
linked to uh you know books. So your LLM
host here. So let's just take the
example of cloud since you know MCP is
from anthropic. So cloud would be your
LLM host. Your MCP server would be
probably implemented by your book
provider because typically they are the
most experts as at serving such content.
And we could assume that the book
provider MCP server has tools regarding
finding books or recommending
them. And then the prompts here could be
a ways to
show you how to find a given title or
maybe recommend it with respect to like
some flavor maybe with respect to the
users test taste and some example of
resources here could be the teddy bears
personal collection or maybe top books
that people buy.
Yeah, just just as an example.
Okay, awesome. So now I'm going to come
to potentially the most exciting part of
today today's lecture which is agents.
So we saw how much more powerful LLMs
could become with tools.
Agents could be seen as one layer up
from it. So I'm going to give first uh
definition just so that we agree uh of
like what agent means here. So it's a
system that autonomously pursues goal
and completes tasks on a user's behalf.
So compared to tools, you not only can
perform like tasks uh but you have also
some reasoning uh involved in it. So you
could have like multiple loops of
iterations and this is what different
differentiates an agent from a tool. um
in plain terms when usually people talk
about agents it has that uh recurrence
or like higher level of reasoning baked
into it.
And so I'm going to contrast like the
agentic world with respect to the world
we have seen where um you know you may
have multiple calls to tools
and this new agentic framework is not
necessarily
disjoint from the ones that we presented
before. You could well have reasoning
chains in inside of it. So it's like a
potentially overlapping but the
structure is uh consists of like tool
calls and iterations.
Okay, great. And now I'm going to talk
about a hallmark paper called
um react. So reason plus act which
decomposes possible loops into different
stages.
So
very often times when you have a query
and you want to pursue a goal, you
cannot do it one shot. You need somehow
to decompose the goal into actionable
substeps,
perform each of these substeps and then
come up with the answer. And this is
exactly what React is about. It's about
decomposing
um complex tasks into
uh into loops of things that can be done
atomically.
So here I just want to say one thing. We
decompose these steps into observe, plan
and act. Uh but it doesn't necessarily
have to be called that way or be in that
order. For example, the react paper I
think introduces terms of think,
observe, act. So yeah, you might see the
language changing a bit from paper to
paper, but the high level intuition
remains.
So let's just ground on a very specific
example. So to be in the theme of these
days
weather
uh starts becoming a bit cold and our
teddy bear might be cold in its home. So
let's just have that as an input. Uh you
know my teddy bear is called please do
something and let's see what uh an
agentic workflow could do about it.
So first you have this observe stage
which translates the user query into an
actionable formulation. So when you say
that your teddy bear is cold and you ask
it to do something uh like here in this
observe stage you would link it back to
the notion of temperature. Uh you know
the user teddy bear is cold which may be
due to the current temperature of the
room which is currently unknown. So
right off the bat, you now know that you
need to do something with temperatures.
So this brings us to the next step
called plan where you know that
something is unknown and you need to
find it. Plan will spell that out for
you. So here you want to determine the
temperature of the room. And luckily
among your tools you might have
something that does something in these
lines and this is where you use it. So
the act stage is using all these APIs
that might be in the context. So for
example here if you have get current
room temperature this is the way to use
it. And as I mentioned these tools are
useful when you to the LLM when you
output information back to it that it
can interpret. So this tool returns the
temperature and you need now to
interpret what the temperature means. So
this is why you go back to the observe
stage. You you do um like you you
describe what the world looks like and
what you should do about it. So here uh
you can read that the temperature of the
room is cold. 65 fah
and the observe stage might indicate
that it's colder than expected. So this
is why you need to plan something and
then at the plan stage you're like you
know this this was colder than expected
so I need to increase the temperature
and then you go back to the act stage.
Okay, luckily I know how to increase the
temperature and it has a a function that
can have uh the temperature increase
arguments inputed to it. So you can
adjust the temperature and then uh once
it's done the observe stage
um concludes that the temperature is not
set at the like to the correct
temperature
and this is the time where you can exit
the loop and return the response to the
user.
So here we have increased the
temperature by 5° and then the output
reads that back to the user in the hope
that it has fulfilled the user's query.
So what I described within the loop is
what makes a workflow an agentic one. So
you have some initial query, you have
some actions that you can perform and
then at each stage the LLM tries to see
if it has reached the goal yet. Uh and
then if it has then it will go to the
output stage otherwise it may have more
reasoning loop where uh where it does uh
more work.
So does the definition of agent that I
propose here make sense?
Okay, great. So now taking this a bit
further, you could think of way more
than one agent. You could have an agent
for setting the thermostat. Uh but maybe
in your home you want to manage how
energy is distributed or uh you know air
quality if you have some some settings
to tune. So you can have different
agents and one interesting use case is
to have the user say something to an
agent and potentially have all of them
communicate together.
So um this prompts
uh potential needs for also a
standardization of communications with
uh between agents similarly to what we
have seen between LLM hosts and tools
and this is what prompted Google to
release the agentto agent protocol
earlier this year. So uh yeah, I highly
recommend taking a look at their uh
document specification but just to give
the main lines around it um you you have
some standardization of what an agent
can expose. So it typically exposes a
set of skills. So it can do things and
um and then you know it gives examples
about it so that other agents are aware
of it and what you need to do as a
developer would be to define these
skills and also another key thing is to
define how um the agent executes a given
request. So for example when you execute
a given query what is the status that
you emit to other agents or there is a
cancel method as well where let's say an
agent says you know stop what you're
doing what is the process to cancel an
action. So yeah these are uh kind of
some of the main functions that are that
that people like the agentto agent
protocol asks people to fill out.
Yep.
So the the question is uh is each agent
an LLM with some context to do some
tasks. So you could definitely you know
imagine it you know be the case. Yeah.
So yeah typically in the example that I
mentioned here. Yes.
And the agents operate independently. So
they have their own reasoning loops and
all the other agency is the input and
output.
>> Yep. So the kind of so the remark here
is maybe your token budget can go you
know uh all over the place. So you can
have some uh budget restrictions you
know put in place you know this is a
good point but each of these agents they
would not eat on each other's budget you
know it might eat on your money budget
but you know yeah this is indeed the
concern
okay so I'm going to move uh on to the
topic of safety which I I have not
mentioned so far but that is very
important uh because with these new
capabilities comes a whole string of new
potential issues and you have seen um
these models they have now the ability
to execute actions for you. So you could
think of some harmful actor doing things
that you wouldn't want for you and I
give one example here that could be a
concern data exfiltration.
So let's say you have access to a tool
that can write in a public visible way
um you know data. So let's say you have
I don't know some email agent.
Um so if you have a prompt that for
example says you know write my password
which potentially the tool could have
access to to an email to that address
you could exfiltrate data that is that
belongs to the user out of it. So this
is one typically one risk that you might
have. You can have other safety risks
and I linked a paper here that goes
through some of them. So a tool sword.
So I recommend a read
and uh you know now you might ask you
know what could you do to get around it.
So you have typically two classes of
remediations. one that might come at the
training stage where um if you recall uh
the training process of R1 or even like
other um other models you have this
harmlessness component. So you typically
have data as part of the data mixtures
that you train during SFT and and uh
reinforcement learning that could cover
uh safety. So this is where you could uh
you know remedy these issues. You have
you know another uh option let's say you
have a query that has gone through your
lines of defenses your training lines of
defenses. You can also have inference uh
safeguards for example a safety
classifier that looks at the
conversation so far and that judges
whether the output of the LLM is going
to be safe or not. So you have even that
as a safeguard and uh just as a pointer
I'm going to uh you know talk about like
agent safety bench which uh summarizes
the span of possible safety hazard
hazards and offers a benchmark a full
suit for it. So yeah people can refer to
these benchmarks to know whether their
LLM is safe.
Yeah. And it's a very important topic
and just yesterday there was um like
anthropic revealed that they were the um
like victims of a large scale cyber
attack launched from cloud. So this is
an issue that is uh like so it was also
using like tools and agent capabilities
and they published super detailed report
saying exactly what the uh attackers did
and went step by step through possible
lines of remediations. And this is just
to emphasize how important safety is in
this more capable world. And both
attackers and the line of defense can be
you know more and more sophisticated. So
it's not a lost battle. It's just that
the you know tools we have for defending
against
um like tool you know tool based attacks
you know need to be so we need to have
like such measures in place and with
these measures maybe it's going to be
fine. So I think that was like the
overall mindset of that article which I
strongly recommend to read.
So
I'm going to say a last few words. So
when you talk about agents, you have um
you know this this risk that at every
step of your uh thought process, you
might diverge to something that just
doesn't work. So that is a huge problem.
Let's say if the model doesn't ground to
the output properly or maybe does a
mistake into that argument prediction of
a tool call. So this is one big issue.
uh which is the reason why you don't see
uh you know large scale agents ruling
the world right now because uh it's it's
really like we are limited by these
consequences.
Um and then uh I'm going to talk about
like the developing capabilities of
models that enable you to have this
agentic capabilities. So this is
something that you can uh like like fix
with SFT but uh ideally you wouldn't
want to use SFT to fix reasoning uh gaps
and use the model itself.
And we're going to see uh next week uh
what the evaluation landscape looks
like. So I'm going to reserve it to next
week. And just a few words of advice
regarding building tools or building
agents. Always start small on a very
simple case. For example, find the
nearest pair. Try to see if the your
current implementation and prompt just
works and then start from there. So
start small and then start smart. So
take the the like most capable model
first so that you know the headroom of
where you can go with the current models
and then try to uh gain on latency
capabilities and so on. So yeah, start
correct, start small and then you can
optimize later.
And uh when it comes to debugabilility,
these LLMs, they output chains of
reasoning. So it's always good to look
at them to see what what is going wrong.
And I will close this lecture on a note.
You know what's you know my favorite use
case of using agents right now is uh as
AI assistant is assistant coding. So
this is something I strongly recommend
in case you have a projects that require
you to do you know complex piping of
things you can free your mental load by
delegating some of these tasks and this
is something that is you're going to see
in the real world very much used now uh
but with the caveat that you know please
make sure to learn the foundations of
code know how to code right because your
taste is going to matter most from now
on you know generating code is cheap,
but judging whether a code is correct
and does the right thing. This is the
hard part. And with that, thank you.